there are a lot of fans out there of  course there's been a love triangle with  your characters now for years that have  said let's just resolve this with a  threesome and you were beginning that  you're getting that from you get you  hear that a lot from fans do you not  yeah that's why for the second part of  Mockingjay we were just like let's do it  may want the gang thing let's give him  the game  I have no money Jaipur - you will not be  disappointed the director's cut yeah it  I was just got scared and then I was  like all right we finished movies I  can't get fired yeah hey thanks for  watching please subscribe to my youtube  channel so they will stop making me  shoot these videos please